see if you can evaluate this integral
right over here so I'm assuming you've
had a go at it so let's work through
this together so you you probably
realize that some of the traditional
techniques that we've already had in our
toolkits don't seem to be directly
applicable use substitution and and
others and the key here to realize is we
have a rational expression here where
the numerator has the same degree or
higher than the denominator in this case
the numerator and the denominator have
the same degree and whenever you see
something like that it's probably a good
idea to divide the denominator into the
numerator that's what this rational
expression could be interpreted as X
minus 5 divided by negative 2x plus 2 so
let's do a little bit of algebraic long
division to actually divide negative 2x
plus 2 into X minus 5 to see if we can
rewrite this in a way that where we can
evaluate the integral so let's do that
we're going to take we're going to take
X minus 5 so X minus 5 and divide
negative 2x plus 2 into that so negative
2x plus 2 so look at the highest degree
terms how many times does negative 2x go
into X well it's going to go negative
1/2 times negative 1/2 times 2 is
negative 1 negative 1/2 times negative
2x is just going to be positive X just
like that and now we want to subtract
this yellow expression from this blue
expression and so let's just let me just
take the negative of this and then add
so I'm just going to take the negative
of it and add and so we are left with
negative 5 plus 1 is negative 4 so you
could say negative 2x plus 2 goes into X
minus 5 negative 1/2 times with negative
4 leftover so we can rewrite this
integral our original integral as we can
rewrite it as negative 1/2 negative 1/2
minus 4 minus 4 over minus 4 over
negative 2 X plus 2
DX DX now let's see it looks like we can
simplify this expression a little bit
more the numerator and the denominator
they're both divisible by two all of
these terms are divisible by two
actually we have all these negatives
that always unnecessarily complicates
things so let's actually divide the
numerator and the denominator by
negative two so what are we going to
have then so if we divide the numerator
by negative two of this view this is
negative four this is going to become
positive two then this if we divide
negative two X by negative two that's
just going to become X and then two
divided by negative two is going to be
minus one so our original integral once
again this is just all algebra
everything we've done so far is algebra
we've just rewritten it using a little
bit of algebraic long division our
original integral has simplified to
negative one half and some might argue
that's not simplified but it's actually
much more useful for finding the
integral negative 1/2 plus two over X
minus 1 DX now how do we evaluate this
well the antiderivative of the
antiderivative of negative 1/2 is pretty
straightforward that's just going to be
negative 1/2 X negative 1/2 X but what's
the antiderivative of 2 over X minus 1
and you might be able to do this in your
head the derivative of X minus 1 is just
1 so you could say that the derivative
is sitting there and so we can
essentially do u substitution in our
heads and say ok let's just take the
antiderivative I guess you could say
with respect to 2x minus 1 which would
be the natural log of the absolute value
of X minus 1 if all of that sounds
really confusing I'll actually do the u
substitution so if I would have if I
were to just if I were just trying to
evaluate if I were just trying to
evaluate the integral 2 over X minus 1
DX
I could see okay the derivative of X
minus 1 is just 1 so I could say U is
equal to X minus 1 and then D U is going
to be equal to DX and so this is going
to be we can rewrite in terms of U as
two I'll just take the constant out two
times the N
integral of 1 over u D U which we know
is two times the natural log of the
absolute value of U plus C and in this
case we know that U is X minus one so
this is equal to two times the natural
log of X minus one plus C and so that's
what that's what we're going to have
right over here so plus two times the
natural log of the absolute value of X
minus one plus C and the plus C doesn't
just come from this one this we in
general when we're taking the integral
of the whole thing there could be some
constant because obvious if we go the
other way we take the derivative of the
constant will go away so let me just put
the plus C right over there and we are
done